all right this is a
level 107 pepper panic saga walk through
video
this is a difficult level and i'm sure
if you're watching this video you
already know that
if you haven't read our
full level 107
pepper panic tips guide i suggest you do
that first because you'll understand a
little bit better
the strategy involved
all right so this is tough because you
have these orange peppers that you need
to explode and mr claus is
trying to steal them
and um
it's also tough because it's such a
small tight area in the beginning
so one of the things we mentioned the
guide is about if you get a match that
would
clear two of the cages at the same time
then you get a quick
explosion on the orange
so you're going to do that when you have
a chance
and as you can see we already have
collected one of our orange peppers
now we just want to clear out the middle
so that we can set up shock wave matches
that'll
free these
peppers in the middle from the ice
we don't have a gap set up at the moment
so
we're just going to try to clear some
space
as quickly as possible
and you basically just want to draw
peppers
until you get
a match like this one
and one of the frustrating things is is
that you usually can't
get everything set up fast enough
because as you can see he's one
he's going to steal these peppers right
away
and a lot of the time whenever you
lose the orange peppers it starts to
feel like you're not going to be able to
complete the level
and honestly sometimes you won't be able
to
so even though he's taking our peppers
we're just going to continue with our
plan
we got rid of the ice in the middle
he's going to steal the last orange
peppers on the board so it's it's
it's fine at this point to um
to basically clear out the entire board
whenever those orange peppers are there
you don't want to start a pepper panic
but once they're gone
that's really the only way we can drop
new orange peppers onto the board
because as you can see right now there's
none so we want to start a panic as fast
as we can and that'll give us the
opportunity
hopefully to get some more orange
peppers in play
and you can see them on the right side
they're starting to fall in a little bit
and we should get some more hopefully
whenever it clears out completely
all right so that's a good result those
will be able to match these in the
bottom right hand corner
and create another explosion
and so now we just have to go back into
the middle because we still need to
free the the peppers from the cages
there's no real good moves there that's
going to set up a shock wave so
i opted to
make a big match at the bottom to drop
things and it looks like we're going to
have another pepper panic as a result
and we're going to lose the three orange
peppers on the right side because they
were stage two but
um there's no real way to avoid that
it looks like there's a tee setting up
in the middle
so that's good that'll that'll open the
cages up
we made a five pepper match and a panic
in a row so he'll be down for a few
moves
so hopefully we can set up another
shock wave to shoot the one in the
middle it looks like we can right now
pretty much we're just gonna have to
match these reds on the side
and then we'll be able to get a shot
going down at the at the orange pepper
so that's an example of how you can
complete the level even whenever the
conditions aren't exactly perfect
and it just shows this is an example of
how you need to adapt
based on what the board gives you
the the tips in our in our full guide
are ideal i mean if you can if you can
free up the the
the peppers in the middle from the ice
in the cages in the beginning and just
do it that way then that that's
that's the most common way we've
completed it in the past
but this is just another example so i
hope it was helpful
and
i hope that uh you'll complete the level
soon
you